no
no no
I wanna be a baby
hello
hi GQ and these are our Essentials
it looks like an ordinary keyboard no
I'll just say it's ordinary it's a
one-of-a-kind
um gaming keyboard but what makes it so
special is that all the keys inside are
lubed I put everything together one by
one everything's made from top to bottom
even inside like the plate and it's
metal as well wow so it's very heavy but
it's really heavy yeah so this took like
an hour and a half two hours to make
wait uh
oh yeah it's very heavy it's spicy
does the keyboard help with the game
performance yeah I think so too
are you sure it does are you sure
there's cable and um is it helpful yeah
it's helpful the last time we played
together we we actually played pretty
good so yeah it was this keyboard okay
I will look forward to your performance
yeah thank you so much all right there
we have thank you so much
so we have let's go Pikachu
100.
it's a normal version special wise and
special why is it special it doesn't
have nose oh yeah it doesn't that's true
and it's a baby pickup oh really oh how
can he breathe
When I visit the Pokemon Center
Japan when we were on a maniac tour
there were a lot of Pokemons but this is
one of my favorite yeah
this is the cutest oh interesting no but
it is pretty cute it's what what no no
way
I sleep with it really beside my bed
I want to be a baby
foreign
I really love to hear music during when
I'm on the schedules and
what yeah what are you doing oh oh we
have a story about this the plane time
was coming and we should move on to the
plane and I dropped this in the lounge
and I was carrying my headphone like
this and I try to listen to music and I
recognize that I have no how to cover
yeah ear cup so my brother hyunjin oh
yo bro you forgot something
I was like yo you are my hero yeah
[Music]
um these days I usually work on canvas
but before I work on paper so I'm
guessing there's like a lot of ideas and
drawings yeah just just sketch or just
just wow it's watercolor oh and I can do
it
right that's right you can do it I can
do it you can do it you can do it you
can try it you can try this is where
hyunjin's Masterpiece comes from oh yeah
Masterpiece Masterpiece I start painting
because of
I'm gonna sell this online yeah this is
I use it before I workout it is good for
my muscle yeah definitely you massage
your massage use it after the show too
right after you perform yeah yeah he
works out every nearly every day yeah
and when we go on tour he goes to the
gym so after going Jimmy yeah this is
the ball and he just released his
muscles it's always just sitting in his
bag so it just pulls it out same with
you too yeah very good essential
it's more so I always bring it nice yeah
yeah he's always in like um The Waiting
rooms you know fixing his posture and
like you know using it to fix his body
so um
yeah you know especially because job
where we have to use our body a lot and
taking care of it is very very essential
especially because you know he's been
working out a lot these days yeah oh wow
[Music]
this is my little bottle container of
vitamins it has vitamin D vitamin D and
it has Ester C which is like a boosted
vitamin C I mean because vitamin D we
barely get to see sunlight yeah yeah so
I see it's important to have vitamin D
and multivitamins and vitamin C is to
help with the immune system very simple
but it's essential
um for you know health and well-being so
um in my bag all the time and I slightly
do feel that it helps out so um because
you know we're always performing uh
working on music
um barely getting enough sleep so um
this really helps out
[Music]
my travel speaker oh trouble speak
portable speaker portable speaker
whenever
I am alone at hotel I play music with
this these days I Hear jazz a lot oh
Jazz okay whenever I'm washing or taking
a shower or like before go to sleep
[Music]
especially right now it's um like
there's a lot of uh pollen yeah there we
go
wow sometimes when we have lenses like
so when we before we go on stage we have
our contact lens but like off the stage
or like after a long day and we're still
using those lenses we use these eye
drops to kind of replenish them yeah
yeah yeah so yeah it does help a lot
[Music]
um
oh wow that smells very nice
thanks for joining us Jake here hope you
enjoyed yeah we also have an album out
now called five star so please give it a
listen bye
foreign foreign